and I think the experience so far is
great at all although we have some
hiccups here and there and I'm actually
now talking for my from the Lego room of
my son which I converted into my office
now for the pandemic so I'm Michael
Stipe I'm a Microsoft MVP and I'm the
author of the hot chocolate
Raphael library and today I want to
explore with you what rough world is and
how we can make dotnet better with it so
when I go to conferences and user groups
and lot of them if developers still
don't know what Raphael is what you can
do with it and there's also a list a lot
of misunderstanding what graph will
actually can do for you
so Roth guerre actually was developed by
Facebook in 2012 and they did that
because when they started developing
mobile applications I don't know if any
of you remember that it was actually
quite a disaster for them because they
tried basically to use standard internet
technology like HTML and rest to build
their mobile applications and when these
came out they a lot of criticism but
they are too slow they eat through your
battery life and on top of that they
used a lot of lose a lot of your data
plans so Facebook back then sat down
with the engineers and they looked into
the problem and they discovered that
their application actually had a ton of
data just by starting up so they
basically opened up hundreds of
connection just by opening the
application so in order to explore that
a little bit what actually went wrong
with the application I've prepared a
little demo because I like a lot of
hands on in presentations so start with
the devil
so what I want to do with you is
basically salt a little algorithm here
what we want to do is basically fetching
and fetching data from REST API that is
called the Star Wars API and our little
algorithm that we want to create with
the Stowers API is to fetch all the
characters that appeared alongside luke
skywalker
in movies it's an easy enough task we
just want to build up a list of names
with all the characters that appeared in
Star Wars movies alongside loops color
and there is a API that is called swap
eco or I'm using now a different clone
of it which basically gives us all the
data and in rest data is organized in
resources so rest services typically
expose like resources through endpoints
and they are easy experiment on this
service we have four instances of people
and point that exposes all the
characters of Star Wars that appeared in
any movie we have other resources like
the firm resource and species resource
Starship resource and home that you that
is associated with Star Wars and it's
kind of if we want to build our
algorithm that fetches all the
characters that appear together with
luke skywalker's we might want to start
and fetch maybe first the people's end
point and look what data it has so if we
fetch the people's list here then we
would get to though as we expect maybe a
list of characters and these if we look
into the data it's easy understandable
because it's just jay-z instance we have
here a luke skywalker character and the
next is maybe a three CPU and so on or
the character and and we also can see
that we down here have attribute called
URL which is pointing to the reference
to this specific object so if you would
follow that along we would get the loot
the single Luke Skywalker
object and it's again easy to explore if
we look for the data that we need for
our I've no reason we might see okay
there's a name in the character object
which is good because we want to build a
list of names and then I can see here
there is an array of films and when I
think about it we just need to grab
these items that are in the array of
therms and if you look at that is again
reference is pointing to the actual
movie objects there I could again follow
these along and get basically the
specific movie objects and I again see
that lots of like there's a title of the
movie there is a opening for describing
the movie and also we can see there is a
character's array again with lots of
references pointing to the characters so
it's easy now to guess how we would need
to build our algorithm to fetch that
data so let's head over to visual studio
code when I prepared already this
algorithm and let me scroll to the rest
huh gruesome and let me walk you through
that it's the only JavaScript I will
show today the other code is all nice
done it so basically the first thing
that we do is we go to fetch luke gonna
fetch the character one and then we
basically start iterating over the
movies array and then we're gonna fetch
each of those movies and then we're
gonna iterate over each of those movie
objects characters array and fetch each
of the characters because these are
actually the characters that we want and
then we just extract from their payload
the name and if we look at this already
we already can see that this might be
not the best approach to fetching data
because we will have a lot of requests
that are dependent on each other so I
have the program already here let up
because my internet is not so good
let me get my prepared version here
this one and I already ran this test
hood in the morning and I would actually
do it life but with my network issues I
refer to that a fixed version so what we
can see basically is that that our have
arisen rent for thirty thirteen seconds
and it took sixty two requests and we
can already see that we have kind of a
data waterfall where we have the
emulation request and then our movie
requests waited for this one and then
issued more requests and this is exactly
what happened with the Facebook app
basically they fetched their their
timeline and then had to fetch the
comments had to fetch other related data
and took forever to get all the data
display and the another thing here yes
you also fetch a lot of data that you
don't need you can see there are like
577 bytes here 780 bind there and
actually I just want the name so let's
let's let's have a peek how we would get
at such a problem was wrapped well so I
have another program prepared here I
basically rewrote we wrote that I just
rewrote the graphical server on top of
the rest service behind that and that is
basically exporting this Star Wars API
in a draft platform okay so this 2 is
called banana cake pop is is built by
our project and it is an awesome way to
explore Bradford API so I put in my
graph where service right here and when
I click here on the left hand side on
the book I can I can see that there is a
very root type and I have a field called
character that is basically the data
that I can vary for so I can already
look at that so if I want to explore
that more I can click on that character
here and I can see okay let returns a
character
and the character has like a couple of
heels here and I can see this character
exposes a movie when I click on that I
can see old it returns a movie object
it's different and with the rest
approach where I got this references to
the movie here I get the actual object
and I again can explore my movie object
here and see that I can call the carrots
so basically like the rest so let's go
back to my Trebek pay and so in this
Bradford IDE on the left hand side I can
write my query on the right hand side I
can get the result so let's explore how
we would write a graphic Remy
so in rough I would start with the
keyword query and then with curly braces
and then the tool will already help me
along and today offer me what I can do
so in this case I can ask the character
the character needs an ID and I already
know from the resting point that my ID
is 1 and I actually can drill into that
I for instance and pick the name of the
character and maybe just let's execute
that and see Oh awesome
I just get that back what I am requested
so I asked for the character of Luke and
I get back the Luke Skywalker character
there ok let's let's explore that
further I can drill into the date of his
I can pick the movies and I may be asked
for the title of the movie and then I
also can drill into the characters and
ask for the name of the character it's
issued that request boom I already have
the data it's super fast and remember
behind that service is the actual rest
service that we used earlier but it's
much faster in here and I can already
see I quite have what I want but
actually why I'm losing let's get rid of
these two
and basically I'm done so compare this
to the algorithm that we had to write
for the rest service and here I just
wrote the graph query and send it over
HTTP to
my graphical server and get exactly the
data back that I need nor creation on
the client the aggregation is done in
the cloud where we have unlimited
bandwidth and where we are close to our
micro services ok let's go back to our
benchmark I pre ran this also and when
you look the benchmark actually says 105
milliseconds for to fetch these
characters but actually it was 47
milliseconds that it needed
yeah because wrong some kind needed to
queue the request and actually it only
needed 70 47 milliseconds to fetch this
data of a graph when compare that to the
30 second 13 seconds at the same time
that I needed to touch that all the rest
okay let's go back to our slides let's
reflect a bit on that so with raft well
I have a consumer of the API and in the
driver seat I define what data I want I
define the shape and I define how deep I
want to drill into the graph and the
server will give me with basically
filled out that graph you can maybe
think of rough way when you get started
with it it is not like that but you
can't think of it like an empty J's and
graphs that you sent to the server and
the server please learn up and that
means request and response closely
aligned and that is by design and one of
the big features so we could also do
dynamic requests was rest right we could
wait something like this Amazon shop a P
I that can do lots of things but
actually with rest it's all it's more
complicated because with rest basically
the consume of the API was implemented
the back-end developer have to closely
work together because the front-end
developer might have a requirement to
support needs a smaller or larger
request that has more
data or less data or needs an optimized
request so he has to walk to the back
end developer and request the back end
developer has to build that in and
there's a lot of back-end force and
often things to over owners we have
multiple iterations of trying to fix
that fix that service that we actually
want to build and there's a lot of
frustration so what is graphic well
actually so graph well is a query
language or your API and runtime to
execute on those execute those queries
and in an ideal world or that's actually
how Facebook did it you would put a very
thin layer of grudge cloud over your
business layer so you have with
graphical a way to expose your business
logic in a much better way because the
graphical type system knows things like
interfaces Union types objects scalars
and you have a very rich type system
that is enforced by the query engine but
graphical is very flexible so you don't
have to do that in that way
we can also put that over microservices
or you can put it over hold sub
infrastructure and basically create from
those fragmented microservices one
monolithic throughs of sorts of tools
from which you actually can pick the
data like you needed and the graph query
engine will aggregate the data from
those different sources very efficiently
with execution plans or data loader and
stuff like that so with wrapper and we
strive for this one single source of
choose where we can pick everywhere pick
the data from its as some kind a fixed
for the micro service world so that we
still can interact with one endpoint and
exposes our data and this allows us to
touch everything in one week first
because we control the requests we built
the week
and that basically fixes the n plus one
problem falls on the client-side because
we don't have over fetching and all
fetching is every time I had to consume
some data from my rest service that I
actually didn't need when since the
first initial Luke Skywalker checked and
the movies objects I didn't need them
really I just needed to fetch them
because there was a reference to another
object and that's also what under
fetching is about every time I hit one
of those references those new eyes and I
needed to fetch some other data that's
basically under fetching because I
actually didn't want the reference I
wanted the object behind and graph is
built on a strong type system and we
won't see that in further demo what that
really means because these from type
system I said we have interfaces we have
objects and really secures me as a
front-end developer and also me as a
back-end developer because I can put the
data that we expose in a very strict
type model type of type model and graph
well in real time and real time is so
simple with graft well since you
basically write a simple query and we
can make that real time we will see that
also and all of this makes graphically a
very predictable to use so what I've
told you so far is basically that which
raft where we can give the lines or the
on the developers the power to ask
exactly for the or what they want I
basically told you so far that we can
basically drill into the data as we want
so there was a nice article on medium
about that when Airbnb introduced draft
well and basically the reaction from the
second Ebola class was not so good in
the beginning but actually ruff has a
real opportunity for back-end developers
because we are second developers are now
able to
is described our data in a much stronger
way with strong types and we can define
how you issue you can request we can
control what complexity a query can have
we can put in there's things like
persisted Crabbie's to make it a very
efficient to fetch your data so rough
way is actually really an opportunity
and if we look back at the history of
Facebook it was actually developed by
second engineers to solve back-end
problems okay and Raphael if we look at
how prefer words so in graph per week
very data through you types we learn
already the first one type which is
called Trevin it's basically a side
effect with a side effect we fetch of
data you could compare it to the get in
rest and side effect means that the
server basically can optimize the data
fetching too so that it fetches most
data in parallel to get the data faster
and then we have something that called
is called mutation and that is basically
the right request and mutations have
side effects because they change data on
our server and it basically compares to
the put post patch and delete I never
knew what to for to choose all those but
in rough words just a mutation and then
we have the subscription you type which
basically is our event system or pops up
it's our real time data fetching so this
makes the graphical I'll really awesome
to use because you have all the data
capabilities that you need you have the
stateless data interaction with queries
and mutation and you have the stateful
connection with reference subscriptions
so let's have head to my next demo to
explore bit what that actually means let
me get to my console and h1 project and
let's pick operation
that was so this is another Star Wars
example this server has a bit more
operations so let's just I'm in the
localhost about 5,000 of QN defects that
okay our schema has already refreshed I
can see this it's no longer valid and we
can see I have known much more I have
here my query types and I have my
mutation type I have my subscription
type and if we would drill into those
things we can see okay and the character
type now actually is an interface oh
that is some kind row just refresh that
and get back into yeah now my character
return type is no longer object it is an
interface it is implemented by droid and
human that means I have a much richer
data model now let's explore first how
we can query instance with interfaces so
we could ask for character therefore
let's ask for the year off of a specific
episode maybe let's say Empire and then
we can fetch data so that is simple we
did that before
it's Luke Skywalker but since we have no
interfaces we can look at specific
aspects of our character so we could say
so if this object is a human then give
me for instance the home planet if we
fact that we get this specific property
of this specific specific object because
now it's a human but if we switch to a
different fetch and fetched r2d2 we
wouldn't get that property because now
it's a droid and we couldn't do that by
saying okay if it's a droid I actually
want
the primary function of that awesome so
this is you can already see that there
is much more possible with data fetching
and graphical so because time is short
let's head to mutations so mutation
means we can change data and I now have
mutation here that is called rate review
and I am able to write revenues for
certain episodes so I could say I want
to write a review and let me add some
stars maybe five stars do a commentary
good movie and and then and then they
actually in graph where you don't have
like mutations that which are nothing
you may always return something like I
could really select the data that I have
written written in actual graphic
implementations you basically would be
query all the objects that your rotation
has affected and that allows you to
instantly update stores like a relay or
an Apollo with the correct ID set the
server produced or stuff like that so
let's just execute that okay awesome
it doesn't feel awesome because it's
just we had data that we had but bear
with me in a second so let's create a
new tap here because I said we have
real-time data and those real-time data
most often driven by mutations so a
real-time query would start in this case
with subscription with the keyword
subscription and I now have things like
over there on review when there is a
review and the review is written for
Empire Strikes Back for this episode and
actually I want this task because I'm
writing like Elissa application that
aptly aggregates now the stars for every
given review of episode so I know
execute that and actually nothing
happens because my referee now starts to
listening
for this issue the query to the server
and the server who are keep it now a
connection with us and only sends us
messages when we issue requests
I put open the results tab here and if
we go now back and issue now requests
here you can see that my results tap on
the other than my other tab with my
real-time data
I already had three results here with ok
with five stars I could change that and
just to see that it's not fake vn and I
get basically my last result three stars
back so that's real time and it it feels
the same way as as if you would write
Brad Claire
Remy okay that's good
without that let's leave that open of
this server and then head back to our
slides because I have to learn more
demos okay so we looked at what Rack
fairness let's also look at what black
squared is not a graphic way that has
nothing to do with the graph database
query language often people think
Ruffman
is it a graph database language for I
don't know it has nothing to do with
that it initially Facebook called graph
well actually super graphs that was the
internal name but I think with the name
brassware they really did a better
choice but they still sometimes confused
with and it's actually graphical is not
bound to any specific data source I said
we can put it over our microservice we
can put it over a square we can put it
over our an API so it is not bound to a
specific data source and it's not
Facebook's version of whoo data it's
capable it has so much more capabilities
than raw data and has a different
mindset if you look at the design and
also graph there is not a good solution
for binaries if you look at Netflix
Netflix is using graph that is using
graph glare but they are not using graph
query to stream movies because if we
looked at profiles so far it's very good
for data well very
where you have data with relations where
you drill in and stuff and an important
aspect is also that graph coil is not
bound to http it's a reference actually
transport agnostic and our project is
releasing rough plan on G RPC in August
so you can't put it any actually on
anything
we already supported on WebSockets over
on signal art on HTTP and you could put
it on any transporter and graph is also
not limited to JavaScript and if you
look at the history of of graph where
you actually see that it was designed to
improve data fetching for mobile
applications and maybe run on a bad
network and actually the first graph
player server what's written in PHP by
Facebook because in the days they used
mostly PHP okay so let's have another
demo and let's have a look how we would
use graphical in.net and now we will do
actual coding okay so I will use just
three code and open that up okay
actually make that let us be smaller and
thinking so this project here is a
simple empty empty hey speed up the core
project
it basically is a Dublin core 3.0
project in this instance it has not been
reference types on just keep that in
mind and it has hot chocolate HP that
make or packaging but apart from that we
have an empty experiment
a empty start up here and there's
nothing in there so how would we go
about writing a graph query server we
saw that it's about blue types so we
have maybe types like Fermi type so we
could start writing a classic fairy
okay bye what now we need something to
return let's maybe create a character P
object so we create another class called
character wallet and parties I have
already prepared some properties maybe
we have a two properties here an ID ID
property and a name property and then we
might just go here in our very class and
say okay we will be turning a character
and the character is maybe called yet
characters and we're just doing a new
character and then maybe run it but
let's go a bit further let's maybe say
we have a string here at the string its
name and it has a default maybe Luke and
actually let's feed in the name here to
look so how do we get this to be become
graphed well so what we could do is or
what we have to do is we add a schema to
our services with the extension method
at GraphLab and there is something
called in hot chocolate that is the
schema below you basically say
schema builder a new and very type that
is our root type and then say and aqua
here then we actually are done our
schema is ready it should be a valid
schema and but we need one more thing
we need something to execute on our
schema that is say HP don't need commit
aware called use graphical and that
actually just a magic let's do it
and over to our graphical IDE we've had
actually the schema that's right okay
and we have our a root type view it has
actually it has the field character and
we can expand this and then we can see
it has an argument name and also
correctly inferred the default value
that we pass in that is loop that's
awesome
and it also because we are using the
nullable reference types it also
detected okay string this exclamation
mark means this string actually is an
inaudible type so if I go now back into
my a query here I can say give me that
character actually I put something else
in let's fetch that name boom and I'm
done
it's so easy to create a draft endpoint
but there's actually more to that and
you can do much more complex graph query
services like in many implementations
you have to use use like type like like
type classes to use some kind of a
fluent API to tell the graph engine how
the type of structure you can do that
with hot chocolate as well because it's
a useful thing if you don't own the
library or if you're if you are
character asked for instance lives in a
different library and you can't change
it and maybe doesn't use known alibi
reference types and we could use a type
class like that and we could tell that
field for instance a Aidid it should
actually be the type ID tag and then we
could basically tell our route type
actually this type now is the graph
where
raph 12 type of evolved corrector time
which will Jen which now would tell the
engine from this fault well what you
return here is actually a corrector type
and take your type information
yep you could also have a character type
class at a class for Prairie and put
that also in the schema builder we will
figure that out or chop is very good in
your fur in your types ok let's move on
let's close that get back to our slides
so awesome we did our first graph for a
server in under two minutes and donut
a.net and you saw it is quite easy to
build so but there's this hello world
examples of over-simplistic i know most
of the times people ask us i have their
I use entity framework I have an entity
model how can we use that with hot
chocolate in graphic where make my old
object with a new world okay let's head
to our next demo and think oh it is how
we think so let's have a look at more
code so I go to this next demo and I
took this demo it's not any more Stowers
it's now from total university because I
went to the Microsoft to the Microsoft
Docs and they actually have an example
to use entity framework with asp.net
quote and there they basically have this
new context it's called the controller
University and they have like entities
like this students and basically our
student has a lot of enrollments two
courses at the University and the
enrollment basically exposes
relationship but also the environment
has a property great which is great for
this course that was reached and the
course is then again have like the
credits that you would earn as a student
at that course so how can we spin a
rough conserve around this so again it's
a stunner asp.net application adjust it
a bit logging here and extra logging
because you will see why in a second and
our startup is a bit more prepared
because I now have B context I already
set up this Emma here there's actually
nothing in the schema yet it's just an
empty schema builder and I also set up
the graphical middleware and I'm also
initializing the database when we start
so a very simple set up so as we did
before we would probably start by
writing our class query Cosette is our
new type which was which with which with
which we would fetch the data and we
would basically start by maybe saying
okay we want to first fetch the students
let's let's let's write a function that
fantasy students so we would write a
variable here and that maybe is a
credible off student and then we would
call this get students made and then we
need some and in in graph glad
everything is resolved a specific
because I can use fields on use them not
it's good for the execution engine to
actually know what we are using so we
could use like a service in here and the
service actually for us is the school
context so are you using the school
context and then we can take this a
school context and which is a DB context
and basically fetched from that the
students let's check let's just return
the students
and then we grab this creamy type and
basically and that to our scheming build
up you say that very tight worried and
maybe just run this thing or net rather
watch run because we're gonna change it
further okay so the thing is they're
getting up it is second okay we can see
already as well because it's checking if
our data is there and it's oh here it's
the same pod store or roughly IDs
shortly messed up okay so I can already
see I have the students there awesome
but when I look closer I can already see
Oh a healthy enrollments there and if I
drill in I can already see I have the
courses there okay so the schema builder
actually inferred automatically our full
object model and if I'm starting to
query that I actually can query maybe
the students last name maybe I can take
the even Romans here and let's get the
course of course title and maybe let's
also get the great okay awesome let's
fire it up
okay disappointment I have to name but I
don't get the enrollment know how it
works yet so we can head back to our
very class here and there's something in
broth well that is called in our
Bradfield implementation that is called
few middleware so we can't tell our
graphic engine it should use maybe
selections and selections basically is a
projection middleware that knows now it
understands variables and it understands
how to navigate data okay so let's go
back in here I have an up and boom I get
the data I get all the data the graph
coil Crimea engine now knows that this
is
and very good and that they can rewrite
expression trees on that side and if we
look at our output here we can see that
it wrote that we brought basically the
incoming craft well into SQL and we can
do actually more because we have
momentum in Midwest
so we could say use filtering and we
could say maybe use sorting and because
it's actually not safe to expose the API
like best we also want to use eg
okay it's recompiling nothing